Au centre-ville de Rennes, sous l’ancien
hôpital de l’Hôtel-Dieu, les archéologues
de l’Inrap (Institut national de recherches
archéologiques préventives) découvrent
actuellement l’ancienne cité romaine de
Condate.
Au centre-ville de Rennes, sous l’ancien
hôpital de l’Hôtel-Dieu, les archéologues
de l’Inrap (Institut national de recherches
archéologiques préventives) découvrent
actuellement l’ancienne cité romaine de
Condate. Depuis l’an dernier et jusqu’en
avril 2017, ils retrouvent sur 7 500 m2 les
origines de la capitale bretonne, fondée
par les Romains vers l’an 10.
Romuald Ferrette et son équipe de 15 archéologues
mettent au jour le quartier antique, avec
ses rues qui se croisaient à angles droits,
ses commerces et ses maisons. Leurs poutres,
leurs murs et des restes d’objets comme
des céramiques venues du centre de la Gaule
ont été retrouvées, ainsi que des restes
de consommation, notamment des coquillages,
des moules, des huîtres ou des os de porc.
Au milieu du chantier de fouilles, les chercheurs
ont découvert un long mur massif de 50 m
de long. Il remonte au premier siècle de
notre ère. A l’ouest de ce mur, sous les
bâtiments en dehors du chantier de fouille,
il y avait un espace végétal autour d’un
monument public. Les archéologues ont deux
hypothèses sur ce monument encore invisible
: c’était le grand sanctuaire de la cité,
un temple romain, ou bien il s’agissait
des thermes publics.
Du côté nord de chantier de fouilles, la
demeure d’un notable de l’époque gallo-romaine
a surgi du passé. Cette domus, une grande
maison romaine d’au moins 200 m2, avait
des murs épais, un sol en béton, formé
de sable et de chaux, et sa salle de réception
était chauffée par le sol grâce à un système
d’hypocauste. La maison avait au moins un
étage. Sur les murs de deux pièces, les
archéologues ont retrouvé des traces d’enduit
peint : ces salles étaient décorées par
des fresques.
La demeure a été abandonnée vers la fin
du 3e siècle. Avec le déclin de la civilisation
romaine, la ville a construit des remparts
en récupérant des matériaux dans les bâtiments
romains. Des tombes sont creusées dans les
gravats et dans les rues abandonnées. Le
site devient un cimetière bien organisé
: 110 squelettes ont été découverts, il
y en aurait au total 300. C’était une vaste
nécropole au 4e siècle. Les premiers chrétiens
y furent enterrés, comme l’indique l’orientation
est-ouest de leurs tombes.
Très peu d’objets ont été trouvés dans
les fosses avec les squelettes. Quelques monnaies
de la fin du 3e siècle, une bague en verre
et, dans la tombe d’un enfant d’environ
5 ans, un vase rouge du 4e siècle. Cette
poterie posée près de la tête du jeune
défunt vient de l’est de la Gaule.
Sur l’ensemble du site archéologique, les
chercheurs ont découverts des dizaines d’objets
au total, notamment une cuillère, une clef
–bague du 1er siècle, qui ouvrait un coffret,
ou un vase avec manche du 1er ou 2e siècle,
qui servait aux libations. Une statuette en
terre blanche est une Vénus du 2e ou 3e siècle.
C’est un objet de piété populaire, fabriqué
dans le centre de la Gaule. Un manche de couteau
du 3e siècle présente une scène de chasse
: un chien qui course un lièvre. Des centaines
de pièce de monnaie ont également été
trouvées.
Le site est devenu un champ de foire au Moyen-
Age, puis un hôpital au 19e et 20e siècle.
A partir de 2017, la société Bâti-Armor
va y construire cinq immeubles avec 200 logements.